The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: So we have
this wanted information
and unwanted information.
Not-- I call-- unwanted
information noise
and wanted information signal.
Not all noises
are created equal.
There are some noises which
are partially understood,
and I'm claim this is what we
should strip off very quickly,
like linear distortions
of speaker dependencies.
Those are two things I
will be talking about.
You can easily do it in
a future instruction.
There are noises
which are expected.
But efforts may not
be well understood.
These should go
into machine land,
but this is what I'm going--
this is something which we--
whatever you don't
know, you better
have the machine to learn.
It's always better to
use the dumb machine
with a lot of training data
than putting in something
which you don't know for sure.
But what you know for
sure, it should go here.
And then there is an interesting
set of the whole noises, which
you don't know that they are--
they even exist.
These are the ones which
I'm especially interested,
because they cause us
the biggest problems.
Basically, the word you
don't know that it exists,
noises which
somebody introduces--
they've never talked about,
and so on, and so on.
So I think this is an
interesting problem.
Hopefully, I will get to it
towards the end of the talk--
at least a little bit.
So some noise is
with known effects.
One is like this.
When you have a--
you have a speech--
oh.
VOICE RECORDING: You are yo-yo.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: And
you have another speech
which looks very different.
VOICE RECORDING: You are yo-yo!
HYNEK HERMANSKY: But it
says the same thing, right?
I mean this is a child.
This is a adult. And you
can tell this was me.
This was my daughter
when she was 4-- not 30.
The problem is that
different human beings
have different vocal tracts.
Especially when it
comes to children,
vocal tract is
much, much shorter.
And I was showing
you the effects
of what happens is that you
get a very different set
of formants like these dark
lines, which a number of people
believe we should look at if
we want to understand what's
being said.
We have four formants here, but
we have only two formants here.
They are in approximately
similar positions,
but where you had
a fourth formant,
you have only
second formant here.
So what we want--
we want some techniques
which would work more
like a human perception, not
look at the spectral envelopes.
But mainly you look
at the whole clusters.
So this is a technique which has
been developed a long time ago,
but I still mention it because
it's an interesting way
of going about the things.
So it uses several things.
One is that it suppresses the
signals at low frequencies.
You basically use this
equal loudness curve.
So you emphasize the
parts of the signal
each child heard well.
Second one that uses
this is critical bands.
Because you say, first
step which you want to do
is to integrate
overcritical band.
This is the simplest
way of processing
within the band--
is you integrate
what's happening inside.
So what you do, you take
your full ear spectrum.
This is the spectrum which
has equal frequency resolution
at all times and a lot of
details with this case,
because it's a
fundamental frequency.
And here you integrate over
these different frequency
bands.
They are narrower
at low frequencies
and getting broader, and
broader, and broader,
very much how we learned
from the experiment
with the simultaneous masking.
So this is a textbook knowledge.
So you get a different spectrum,
which is unequally sampled.
So, of course, you go back
into the equal sampling,
but you know that
there is fewer samples
at the high frequencies,
because you are integrating
more spectral energy
at high frequencies
than in low frequencies.
And you multiply these outputs
through these equal loudness
curves.
So from the spectrum
you get something
which has a resolution, which
is more like auditory-like.
Then you put it through
the equal loudness curves,
because you know
the loudness depends
on a cubic root of intensity.
So you get a modified spectrum.
And then you find
some approximation
to this spectrum--
auditory spectrum--
saying, that I
don't think that all
these details still
have to be important.
I would like to
have some control
of how much spectral
detail I want to keep in.
So the whole thing looks like--
let's start with the spectrum.
You go through--
a number of steps.
And you end up with
the spectrum, which
is, of course, related to
the origin of the spectrum,
but it's much simpler.
So we eliminated information
about fundamental frequency.
We merged number of foramens
and so on, and so on.
So we follow our philosophy.
Leave out the stuff which you
think may not be important.
You don't know how much
stuff you should leave out.
So if you don't know something,
and you are engineer,
you run an experiment.
You know, research is
what I'm doing when
I don't know what I'm doing--
supposingly.
I don't know where now--
from Brown or somebody
was saying that.
So we didn't know what's-- how
much smoothing we should do
if we want to do our-- speaker
independent representation.
So we ran an experiment
for a number of smoothing,
a number of complex
poles telling you
how much smoothing you get
through auto-regressive model.
And there was a very distinct
peak in the situations
where we had a
training coming for--
templates coming from
one speaker and the test
coming from another speaker.
Then we used this
kind of representation
in a speech recognition--
I mean in a--
to derive the features
from the speech.
Suddenly, these two pictures
start looking much more
similar, because what
this technique is doing
is basically interpreting
the spectrum in a way
the hearing might be doing.
It has much lower resolution
that normally people would use.
It has only two peaks, right?
But they say that it was good
enough for speech recognition.
What was more
interesting about--
a little bit of
interesting science
is they also-- found that
difference between production
of the adults and the
children might be just
in the length of the pharynx.
This is a back part of the vocal
tract; that the children may
be producing speech
in such a way
that they are
putting already the--
[AUDIO OUT] constriction
into right position
against the palate.
And because they know--
or they-- well,
whatever-- mother nature
taught them that pharynx
will grow in the lifetime.
But the front part of the vocal
tract is going to be similar.
So it is the front cavity
which is speaker independent,
and it is the back cavity,
the rest of the vocal tract,
which may be introducing
speaker dependencies.
It's quite possible
if you will--
if you ask people how they've
been treated-- like actors--
on how they are being trained to
generate the different voices,
they are being trained to modify
back part of the-- vocal tract.
Normally, we don't
know how to do.
But there is some
circumstantial evidence
for this might be at
least partially true.
So what is nice is that when
we synthesize the speech
and we made sure that
front cavity is always
in the same place, even
when the foramens were
in different positions, we were
getting very similar results.
So we have this theory.
The message is encoded in the
shape of the front cavity.
Through speaker-dependent
vocal tracts,
you generate the speech
spectrum with all the formants.
But then there comes the
speech perception fine
point, which extracts
what is called
perceptual second formant.
Don't worry about that.
Basic-- [AUDIO OUT] on the--
at most, two peaks
from the spectrum.
And this is being used for
decoding of the signal, speaker
independently.
However, I told you
one thing, which is
don't use the textbook
data and be the exact--
[AUDIO OUT]
And so I was challenged
by my friend, late
Professor Fred Jalinek.
He is claimed to say,
airplanes don't flap wings,
so why should we be putting
the knowledge of the hearing
in-- actually, he said
something quite different.
This is what The New York Times
quoted after he passed away,
because that was one
of-- supposedly one
of his famous quotes.
No, he said something else.
Well, if airplanes
do not flap wings,
but they have a
wings nevertheless.
They use some knowledge
from the nature
in order to get the job done.
The flapping of the
wings is not important.
Having the wings
is important if you
want to create the machine
which is heavier than the air
and flies.
So we should try to
include everything
what we know about human
perception, and production,
and so on.
However, we need to estimate
the parameters from the data,
because don't trust the
textbooks and that sort
of thing.
You have to derive in such a way
that is relevant to your task.
What I wanted to say--
you can use the data to
derive the similar knowledge.
And I want to show it to you.
What you can do is to
use a technique again,
known from the '30s, called
Linear Discriminant Analysis.
This is the
statistician's friend.
For this you need a within-class
covariance and between class
covariance matrix.
You need the labeled data.
And you need to make some
assumptions, which turns out
are not very critical.
But I mean, they
are approximately
satisfied when you are
working with the spectra.
So what we did was we would
take this spectrogram,
and we would generate the
spectral vectors from that.
So we would always cut
part of the spectrum,
or short term the
spectrum, and we assign it
to the label from which
part of speech it came from.
So this one would have
a label, "yo," right?
And so you get the big
box full of vectors.
All of them are labeled.
So you can do LDA.
And you can look what they are--
discriminants are telling you.
From LDA, you get the
discriminant matrix
and each of the row of the--
column of the-- column or row--
whatever-- creates the basis
on which you should project
the whole spectrum, right?
These are the four
obvious ones here.
You also have the
amount of variability
present in this discriminant
matrix which you started with.
What you observe, which
is very interesting,
is that these bases tend
to project the spectrum
at the beginning,
with more detail,
than the spectrum at the end.
So essentially, they
tend-- they appear--
in the first-- group they appear
to be emulating properties
of human hearing, with some
of the well known properties
of human hearing, namely,
non-equal spectral resolution
being verified in any
ways-- many, many ways.
Among them was one--
I was showing you this masking
experiment of Harvey Fletcher.
There is a number of
reasons to believe
that this is a good thing.
This is what you see.
So essentially, if you
look at the zero crossings
of these bases-- this
is the first base--
they are getting
broader and broader.
So you are integrating more
and more spectrum, right?
This is all right--
so that I leave it.
Oh, this is from
another experiment
with a-- very large database,
very much and very similar
thing.
Eigenvalues quickly decay.
And what is interesting--
you can actually formally
ask, "What is your
resolution?" by doing what is
called perturbation analysis.
So you take some--
say, some signal here.
This is a Gaussian.
And you project this
on this LDA basis.
Then you perturb it.
You move it.
And you ask, how much effect
this movement of this, say,
emulated spectral element of
the speech causes the output--
seen as the output of this
projection of this many--
on these many bases?
And what do you see is,
as I was suggesting,
spectral sensitivity to the
movements of the formant
is much higher at the
beginning of the spectrum
and much less at the
end of the spectrum.
You can actually
compare it to what
we had-- initially in
the PLP analysis when
we integrated the spectrum
based on the knowledge coming
from the textbook.
And it's very much
the same if there
were just a plain
cosine basis computing
mel cepstrum sensitivity is
the same at all frequencies.
But these bases--
are from the LDA,
they're very much doing the
thing which physical bin
analysis would be doing.
And so this is a--
you can look at it.
It was a PhD thesis from Oregon
Graduate Institute by Naren
Malayath, who is now a big--
you better be friends with him.
He's at Qualcomm.
I think he's a head of
Image Processing department.
[COUGHS] We better-- better
be good friends with him.
[INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Another problem with
linear distortions-- linear
distortions void was a problem.
Now it's not problem
anymore, but in the old days,
this was a problem.
A problem shows up in a rather
dramatic way, in following way.
Here we have one sound.
VOICE RECORDING: Beat.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Beat.
So "buh ee- tuh."
Here is the very distinct E.
Every phonetician would agree.
This is E-- high foramen,
cluster of high of foramens,
and so on.
Some vicious person, namely
one of my graduate students,
took this spectral
envelope, designed a filter,
which is exactly
in reverse of that,
and put this speech
through this inverse filter
so it looked like this.
This was-- there is a spectrum
where there were nine formants.
It's entirely flat.
And if you listened
to it, you've
probably already guessed
what you will hear.
VOICE RECORDING: Beat.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: You'll hear
the first speech, right?
But you--
VOICE RECORDING: Beat.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: It's
OK when this-- oops!
That's what you would--
sorry.
VOICE RECORDING: Beat.
Beat.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: But
whoever doesn't hear E--
don't spoil my talk.
I mean, I think
everybody has to hear E,
even though any phonetician
would get very upset.
Because they say this is
not E. Because, of course,
what is happening, human
perception is taking relative--
percept relative to these
neighboring sounds, right?
And since we filtered everything
with the same filter, I mean,
relative percepts
is still the same.
So this is something which we
needed to put into our machine.
And we did-- actually, this
is a very straight-- signal
processing wise, the things
are very straightforward,
because what you have,
the signal is actually
signal of the speech
convolved with the spectrum
of the impulse response
of the environment.
So in logarithmic domain this
is the signal processing stuff.
Basically, you have a
logarithmic spectrum
of the signal plus logarithmic
spectrum of the environment,
which is fixed.
So-- what we're finding here is
that if you remove somehow this
environment, or if you make it
invariant to this environment
thing, then you maybe win--
you may be winning.
The problem here is
that each frequency
you have a different amount
of additive constant,
because this is a
spectrum, right?
If it was just a constant
at all frequencies,
you just subtract it.
But in this case, you
can use the trick.
You remember what Josh
told us this morning.
Hearing is doing
spectral analysis.
And what I was trying
to tell you, that each--
at each frequency, each
critical band is trajectory
of the spectral energy is
independent of-- in the first
approximation, of the other--
others.
You can do
independent processing
at each frequency band--
and maybe don't screw
up that many things.
So this was a step
which we took.
We said, OK.
We will treat each sample
trajectory differently, right?
But we will filter out
stuff which is not changing.
So related to different
frequency channel,
do the independent
processing channel.
And processing was that we
would take first logarithm,
and then we would do--
then we put each trajectory
through a bandpass
filter, which would--
main thing is which
would be suppressing DC,
and slowly changing components.
Mainly it was suppressing
anything which
was slower than one hertz.
And also, it turned out it was
useful to separate things which
are higher than about 15 hertz.
So what you get out-- this
was the origin spectrogram.
This was the
modified spectrogram.
It seems it got a little
bit-- this trajectory got
a little bit smoother.
Transitions got smoothed
out because there
was a bandpass filter.
There was a high pass
elements to that.
Very much what we thought--
well, this is interesting.
Maybe this is what a human
hearing might be doing.
To tell you the
truth, we didn't know.
It was-- for the
people who are from MIT
and who are working
in Image, it was
inspired by some work on a
perception of lightness, what
David Marr called lightness.
And here was the type--
thing which I told you about--
6 by-- 6 by 749.
David Marr was talking
about processing in space.
We applied it in
processing in time.
But it was still good enough.
I mean, so that we definitely
got rid of the problem.
So here it is.
The spectrograms, which
look very different,
look-- suddenly start
looking very similar.
I was good seeing what's here.
Remember, I'm an engineer.
I was working for a telephone
company at the time.
It was still working
better in some problems
which we had before.
And we had a severely
mismatched environment,
getting the training
data from the labs
and testing it in the
US west, in Colorado.
So it didn't work
at all; recognized
after this processing
everything was cool and dandy.
OK.
So now we have a RASTA LDA.
And we can do the same trick.
How about that?
So we take-- you take the
spectral temporal vectors,
and you label each
of these vector
by the label which is
of the phoneme, which
is in the center
of this trajectory.
And just for the sake of--
just to have some fun, we
took a rather long vector.
It was about one second.
And we said, well, what kind
of projections would these
temporal trajectories would
go on if we wanted to get rid
of a speaker-dependent--
I mean, of an
environment-dependent
information?
Well, these were the
impulse responses.
These were the
frequency responses.
Because in this case,
you get a FIR filters.
These discriminants
are FIR filters,
which are to be applied to
temporal trajectory-- so
spectral energies.
Because it's just
basically projection
of the spectrum on the basis.
And basis is one second long.
This is impulse response.
It cannot be all that
long, because eventually,
they become zero, right, if
you should do nothing to it.
You do do nothing.
But you can see active
part is about a couple
of hundred millisecond,
maybe a little bit more.
And these are the
bandpass filters.
So essentially-- passing
frequency between the 1 hertz
and 10, 15 hertz--
very similar at all frequencies.
There was another thing which
we were very interested in.
We should really
do different things
at different frequencies.
Answer is pretty much no.
And so that was very exciting.
What-- what I-- well, anyway,
so let me tell you-- yet
another experiment which
hasn't happened and is going
to be presented next week.
Well, we wanted to move
in the 21st century,
so we did convolutive
neural network.
And our convolutive
network is maybe not
what you are used to when you
have a 2D convolutions there.
But we just said, we
will have a 1D filter
as a first processing step
in this deep neural network.
So we postulated the filter, the
input, to the neural network.
But in this case, we trained
the whole thing together.
So it wasn't just LDA
and that sort of thing.
So we forced all filters
at all frequencies
be the same, because we expected
that's what we want to get.
And we were asking how
these forces look like,
which come from the
convolutive neural network.
Well, again, I
wouldn't be showing it
if it wasn't really somehow
supportive of what I
want to say.
They don't look all
that different for what
we were guessing from LDA.
They definitely are enhancing
the important modulation
frequencies around
four hertz, right?
They are passing
a number of them.
I'm showing three here,
which are somehow arbitrary.
They are passing-- and most
of them look like that.
And we will use the 16 of them.
Passing between in 1 and
10 hertz in modulation
spectral domain, so changes
which are 1 to 10 times
a second.
It's coming out in a paper, so
you can look it up if you want.
Last thing which I
still wanted to do--
I said, well, maybe
it has something
to do with the
hearing after all.
We were are deriving
everything from speech.
There was no knowledge
about hearing,
except that we said we think
that we should be looking
at long segments of
the signal, and we
expect that this filtering
will be very much the same
at all frequencies.
Actually, not even-- earlier
it come out automatically.
There wasn't much of the
knowledge from human hearing--
[AUDIO OUT] on.
In the first one, when I
was showing you critical
band spectral resolution, we
started this full ear spectrum.
We didn't tell anything
about human hearing.
And what comes out is a
property of human hearing.
I mean, tell me if there is
yet another strong evidence
that speech is processed in such
a way that fits human hearing,
because the only thing
which was used here
was the speech,
labor, into certain--
into classes which we are
using for recognizing it--
speech sounds.
So what we did was-- that
was with Nema, with Garani,
and my students.
We took a number of these
cortical receptive fields--
which we talk about it
before a little bit--
about 2,000, 3,000,
whatever-- we spread--
we basically spread to the floor
at the University of Maryland
and computed
principal components
from these fields in both
spectral and temporal domain.
But here I'm showing
the temporal domain.
How they look-- they are very
much like the rest of filter.
This is what is happening.
It's a bandpass.
Peak is somewhere
around four hertz.
Essentially, I'm
showing you here what
I understood might be a transfer
function of the auditory cortex
derived with all the
usual disclaimers,
like, this is a linear
approximation to the receptive
fields.
And there might have been
problems with collecting it,
and so on, and so on.
But this is what we are
getting as a possible function
of auditory cortex.
I'm doing fine with
the time, right?
So you can do
experiment in this case.
You can actually
generate the speech
which has certain rates
of change eliminated.
By doing all this,
computing the cepstrum,
do the filtering
of each trajectory,
and reconstruct the speech.
And ask people
what do they hear?
How do they recognize speech?
You can also ask, "Do
you recognize it?"
For this you don't have
to regenerate the speech.
But you just use
therapy C cepstrum.
This is the full
experiment with the-- this
is for-- this is called a
residual-excited LPC vocoder.
But it's modified in such
a way that you artificially
slow down or modify the temporal
trajectories, which are being--
if there is no filter,
you cannot make a replica
of the origin, the signal here.
So just the bottom line of
the experiment here is what--
if you start removing
components which
are somewhere between
1 and 16 hertz,
you are getting
hurt significantly.
Most you are getting
hurt in performance
when they are removing
component between 2 and 4 hertz.
This is a-- that's how you
are getting biggest hit.
Here we are showing
how much is--
how much these bands contribute
to recognition and performance
by humans.
This is a white bars; and
to speech recognize it.
Those are the black bars.
So you can see that in
speech recognition, machine
recognition, you
can safely remove
stuff between 0 and 1 hertz.
It's not going to hurt you.
It's only helps
you in this task.
Speech perception, there
is a little bit of hit,
but certainly not
as much hit as you
are getting when you
are moving to the part
where you hear the--
[AUDIO OUT]
And certainly the component that
is higher than 16 or 20 hertz
are not important.
Then, already, Homer
Dudley, he knew, in 1930,
when he was designing
his vocoder.
But it was a nice experiment.
It came out in just--
so you can look it up and--
if you want to have a go.
Just to summarize what
I told you so far,
Homer Dudley was telling
us information from the--
information about the message
in the slow modulation,
slow movements of the vocal
tract, which modulates
the carrier; information
about the message
in slow modulations
of the signal--
slow changes of speech signal
in individual frequency bands.
Slow modulations imply long
impulse responses, right?
So 5 hertz, I sense something
around 200 millisecond.
My magic number of what
physically needs to allow,
which we have observed in this
summation of sub-threshold--
the signals and
temporal masking.
And so I have to hear a number
of things which I listed.
Frequency
discrimination improved.
If you are longer
than 200 millisecond,
below 200 milliseconds
of signal,
you don't get such a good
frequency discrimination.
Loudness increases up
to 200 millisecond,
then it stays constant.
It depends on amplitude.
Effect of forward masking--
I was showing you--
asked about 200
millisecond independent
of the amplitude of the masker.
And sub-threshold integration
is also showing you.
So I'm suggesting there seem
to be some temporal buffer
in human hearing on some level.
I suspect it's cortical
level, which is processing.
Whatever happens
within this buffer,
it's a fair thing to
treat as a one element.
So you can do filtering on it.
You can integrate it; any--
basically, all kinds of thing.
If things are happening
outside this buffer,
these parts should be treated--
[AUDIO OUT] in parts.
So how does it help us?
You remember the story
about the phonemes.
You remember that phonemes
don't look like this,
but they look like this.
Length of the coarticulation
pattern is about 200
millisecond, perhaps more.
So what is a good
thing about it is
that if you look at sufficiently
long segment of this signal,
you will get whole
coarticulation pattern in.
And then you have a chance
that your classifier is getting
all the information
about the speech
sound for finding the sound.
And then you may have a
chance to get a good estimate
of the speech sounds.
But you need to use these
long temporal segments.
And here I can say
it even to YouTube.
I think we should claim
the full victory here,
because most of the
speech recognition systems
do it nowadays.
They use the long segments
of the signal as a first step
of the processing.
So I can happily retire
telling my grandchildren,
well, we knew it.
We were the only ones.
But I mean, we were certainly
using it for a long time
and probably for a long
time, in such a way
that we even designed several
techniques that you do there.
So this is a classifying
speech recognition
from the temporal
patterns directly.
So we would take these
long segments of the speech
through some processing,
put neural nets on every--
every temporal structure,
trying to estimate the sound
at each frequency--
each carrier frequency.
And then we would fuse
all these decisions
from different frequency bands.
And then we would
use the final vector
of posterior probabilities.
Unlike what people
do very often--
most often-- that they just
take the short term spectra,
and then they maybe now take
the longer segment of this block
of these short term spectra.
We say, short term spectrum
is good for nothing.
We just cut it into pieces.
And we classify each temporal
trajectory individually
in the first step.
Tell now that it was used--
it may be useful
later when I will
be telling you about dealing
with some kind of noises.
But you understand what
we did here, right?
Instead of using the
spectral temporal blocks,
we would be using
temporal trajectories
at each critical
event, very much
along the lines of what
we think that hearing is
doing with the speech signal.
First thing is,
hearing is doing.
It takes the signal, sub divides
it into individual frequency
bands, and then it treats
each temporal trajectory
coming from each of
these cochlear filters
to extract the information.
And then it tries
to figure out what
to do with this
information later, right?
Well, we have another
technique called MRASTA, just
for people who are
interested in cochlear--
I mean, in-- cortical modeling.
You take this data.
We project a number
of projections
with variable resolution.
So we get a huge
vector of the data
coming from different
parts of the spectrum.
And then we feed it
into speech recognizers.
The first test looked like this.
I mean, they have a different
temporal resolution,
spectral resolution.
We are pretty much integrating
or differentiating over
three critical bands
following some of the filters,
coming from these three--
I mean, old PLP low order
model and three bark three bark
critical event integration.
So these ones look a
bit like what people
would call Gabor filters.
But they are just put
together, basically,
from these two places in
time and in frequency--
different temporal resolution
enhancing different components
of moderating the spectrum.
Again, you may be claiming
that this is something
which resembles the Thorston--
[AUDIO OUT] Josh was
mentioning in the morning.
It's cochlear filter banks--
[CLEARS THROAT]
auditory, of course.
I mixed up cochlear and
cortical-- cortical filter
bank, modulation filter banks.
So there are some novel aspects
in this type of processing
I want to impress.
It was novel in 1998.
That is, as I said, this is
fortunately becoming less novel
15 years later.
Use is rather long
temporal context
of the signal as a input.
It uses already
hierarchical neural nets.
So deep neural
network processing,
which wasn't around in 1998.
The only thing was that there
was independent processing
of frequency of neural net
estimator at frequencies.
The only thing which we
didn't do at the time,
and I don't know
how important it is.
I don't think it doesn't hurt--
it hurts anybody.
They were training these
parts of the system,
this deep neural
net individually.
And it's just
concatenated output.
So we never did
training all together
as we do now in convoluted
nets and that sort of thing.
Because simply, we didn't
even dream about doing that,
because we didn't
have the hardware.
That was one thing which I tried
to point out during this panel.
A lot of progress in
neural nets research
and success of neural
nets comes from the fact
that we have very, very powerful
hardware, which we didn't have.
So we didn't dream about
many things doing, even when
they might have made sense.
So, OK.
Where are we?
Oh, I see-- one more thing.
Coarticulation.
This is a problem which is
known since people started
looking at the spectrograms.
There's some consonants
like a "kuh", or "huh."
They are very dependent
on what's following.
So "kuh" in front of "ee,
kee, koo, kah, koo-kah,"
we [AUDIO OUT] has a burst here.
In front of "ooh"
has a burst here.
And in front of "ah"
there's a burst here.
So the phonemes
are very different
depending on the environment.
When you start using these
long temporal segments,
you know all the tricks, or
some of the tricks, I showed you
about, what comes out
are the posteriogram
in which the "kuh" almost
looks the same as a "kuh."
It basically recognizes this--
recognizes that since it looks
at the whole coarticulation
pattern or group
of the phonemes,
in order to recognize this
sound, it does the right thing.
So I suspect that success of
these long temporal context
which people are using now
with speech recognition,
comes from the fact
that this partially
compensates for the
problems with-- by problems
for the coarticulation.
And what I also want is
to say-- coarticulation
is not really a problem.
It just spreads the information
for a long period of the time.
If you know how to suck
it out, it can be useful.
But it's a terrible
thing if you start just
looking at individual
frequency events,
even with your frequency's
slices of the short term
spectrum.
So it's another deep net--
deep net from, I
don't know the name.
Sorry.
It was already almost
legal deep net.
You do the-- you estimate
the posteriorgram
from the short window in
the first step for about 40
mm length window.
And then you take the long--
I mean, big window of
the posteriors' tree.
Another neural net you get much
better, which also work better.
Again, the mainstream
technique nowadays
is being used in most
of the DARPA systems.
Oh, yes-- one more thing.
I want to stress this one.
[LAUGHS] So, I'm
sorry I didn't want
to show it all at the same.
But anyways, I don't
think that there's
anything which is terribly
special about short term
spectrum of speech.
I think what really
matters is how
you process the temporal
trajectories of the spectra
energies.
This is what the
human hearing is
doing that seems to be doing
a good job on our speech
recognizers.
So essentially, this is one
message which I want to say.
Don't be afraid to treat
different parts of the spectrum
different.
Individually you may get
some advantages from them.
It started with
your stub, but it
shows up over and over again.
So away from the short
term spectrum, go away,
they start using what
hearing is doing--
start using a
temporal trajectories
of the spectra energies
coming from your analysis.
To the point that we did this
work on real [INAUDIBLE],,
on the-- going
directly, don't do this.
And don't get your
time frequency patterns
from the short term spectra.
I think about always how to
get directly what you want.
It turns out that there
is a nice way of doing--
for estimating directed
hilbert envelopes
of the signal in the frequency
bands called frequency domain
linear prediction.
[STATIC]
Mario says-- there's
his PhD thesis.
And we were working together
for a couple of years.
So what you do, instead of
using the time trajectory,
so use this case,
autoregressive modeling--
LPC modeling-- and put the
windows on a time to get
the frequency--
frequency vectors.
You do it on a cosine
transform of the signal.
So you move the signal
into a frequency domain.
And then you put the windows
on this cosine transform
of the signal.
And you derive directly the--
all polar approximations
to hilbert envelopes
of the signal in the sub bands.
You don't ever do the
hilbert transform.
You just use the
usual techniques
from autoaggressive modeling.
The only difference is--
[AUDIO OUT] on the cosine
transform of the signal.
And your windowing
determines which frequency
range you are looking.
So, of course, what
you typically do,
you can use the longer windows
at higher frequencies, shorter
window of lower frequencies.
You do all these things.
But this is a convenient way.
[COUGHS] It's convenient, and
this is more and more like fun.
But maybe somebody might
be interested in that.
So essentially,
what you do-- oops.
Sorry.
What you do is that
you take the signal,
and you eliminate
modulation component
out of that AM component which
the signal is being modulated.
So this carries the
information about the message.
And this is the carrier itself.
And you can do what is called
channel vocoder, which we did.
And you can listen
to the signal.
So this is-- in some ways it's
interesting-- original signal.
VOICE RECORDING: They are
both trend-following methods.
HYNEK HERMANKSY: Oops.
I tried to make it somehow--
[AUDIO OUT]
VOICE RECORDING: They are
both trend-following methods.
HYNEK HERMANKSY: Somebody may
recognize Jim Glass from MIT
in that.
VOICE RECORDING: In an
ideological argument,
the participants tend
to dump the table.
HYNEK HERMANKSY: So
this is silly, right?
Now you can look at
what you get if you just
keep the modulations and excite
you know, with the white noise.
Oops.
Sorry.
Oops!
What am I doing?
Oh, here.
VOICE RECORDING:
(WHISPERING) They are
both trend-following methods.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Do you
recognize Jim Glass?
I can.
VOICE RECORDING: (WHISPERING)
In an ideological argument
the participants tend
to dump the table.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: And
then you can also
listen to what is left after
you eliminate the message.
VOICE RECORDING: Mm-hmm.
Ha, ha.
[LAUGHTER]
HYNEK HERMANSKY: Maybe
it's a male, right?
VOICE RECORDING:
Mm-mm [VOCALIZING]
HYNEK HERMANSKY:
Oh, this is fun.
This is [CHUCKLES] fun.
It may have some implication
for speech recognition.
But certainly, if I have seen
one verification of what old
Homer Dudley was telling
us-- where the message is--
I mean, this is it.
All right?
Anyways, what is
good in-- for that,
is that once you get an open--
[AUDIO OUT] it's
relatively very easy
to compensate for
your ear distortions.
Because main effect
of linear distortions
is basically shifting the energy
a different frequency by--
bends by different amounts.
But all this information is
in the gain of the model.
It's one parameter
which you essentially
ignore after you do
this frequency domain
linear prediction.
And you get a very similar
trajectory for both.
This is a telephone
speech and clean speech
which differed quite a bit.
And I hope that I have-- oh,
this is for reverberant speech.
There seem to be
also some advantage,
because reverberation is
in the first information,
it is a convolution with the
impulse response of the room.
So you make the--
if you use a truly long
segments-- in this case,
we used about 10 seconds
of the signal approximating
by this open model, and
eliminated the DC from that.
You know, it seems to be
getting some advanced--
[AUDIO OUT]
So known noise with
unknown effects.
I say train the machine on that.
Here is the one example, right?
You have a phoneme error
rates, noise estimate.
If everything is good,
clean, trading clean test,
you have about 20%
phoneme accuracy.
This is a stage of the result--
reasonable result. But once
you start adding a noise,
things quickly go south.
Typical way of dealing with it
is if you train multi-style.
So if you know which choices
you are going to deal with,
you train on them.
And things get better,
but you pay some price.
I mean, certainly, you
pay the price on clean,
because you recognize your model
became must mushier, basically.
It's not a very sharp model.
So here we had a wonderful 21%.
We paid 10% relative price for
getting this better performance
on the noises.
What we observe is that you
get much better results, most
noticeably better
results, if you
would have different recognizers
for each type of noise.
But of course, the
problem is that you
have different types of noise.
So you have this
number of recognizers.
But now you need to
pick up the best stream.
And how do you do that?
This is something, again, which
I was mentioning also earlier.
This is something which
we are struggling with
and we don't know
how to do that.
If you are a human
being, maybe you
can just look at the output.
And you can see, just keep
switching after your message
starts looking reasonably well.
But if you want to do
it fully automatically,
I don't know why we
want to only build
a fully automatic recognizers,
but that's what we are doing.
So you want to pick up the--
you want a system to
pick up the best stream.
So how do we do that?
First thing is, of course--
one way is to recognize
type of noise.
This is a typical
system nowadays.
You recognize type of
the noise, and you use
the appropriate recognizers.
BBN is doing it.
My feeling is that it's
somehow cleaner and more
elegant to be able
to figure out what
is the right output,
because what--
neither.
It's not what is the signal, but
what is the signal interacting
with the classifier?
So for this we have to figure
out what the best means.
So here we have
two posteriograms.
If you look at it, if you know
that these are trajectories
of the posteriors--
of the speech sounds, you
know this one is good.
This one is not so good.
Because the word is nine--
"ne-ine," "ne," right?
Here is a lot of garbage.
So I will know that--
I will do it automatically.
So ideally, I would
pick up the stream which
gives me the lowest error.
But I don't know what the lowest
error is, because I don't know
what the correct answer is.
That's the problem, right?
So one is to maybe try to
see what I-- what my I did?
Try to figure out which
posteriogram is the cleanest.
Another one is
following thinking.
When I trained the--
I trained the neural
net on something.
It's going to work well on the
data on which it was trained.
So I have some gold
standard output.
And then I will try to see
how much my output differs
if the test data, which are not
the same as the data on which
the recognizer was trained.
So both of these
tricks we were using.
So first one uses a
technique which is like this.
You look at the differences
between posteriors
or KL divergence areas a certain
distance from each other,
and you will slice this window.
You cumulatively cover as
much data as you possibly can.
And what you observe is that
if you have a good, clean data,
this cumulative divergence
keeps increasing.
And after you cross the point
where there is a coarticulation
pattern or
coarticulation ceases,
suddenly you start getting
pretty much the fixed high tail
divergence-- cumulative
KL divergence.
If we have a noisy
data, the noise
start dominating this KL
divergences and differences RS.
Because the signal
in the first place
carries the information, and the
information is in the changes.
But noise is creating
the information
which it doesn't have these
segments, or something.
So this is one
technique which we use.
Another technique which is
even more, now, popular,
in at least in my lab,
training of another unit.
We trained this autoencoder
on the output of a classifier.
And we say-- so we--
on the output of
the classifier as
it's being used on the training
data, and we say autoencoder.
Then we learn how in
average the output
from the classifier used on
its training data looks like.
And if-- and then we use it on
the output from the classifier
used to unknown data.
And if the
autoencoders then knew,
then we tried to predict
input on its output.
This is how it is being trained.
So if the output--
if the prediction
is not very good,
then we say we are
probably dealing
with the data for which
the classifier is not good.
It's how it works.
I mean, you know, it's honest.
If you are looking at the
output of the neural net
which has been applied to a--
towards training data, the test
is-- or the test is maybe--
the training data is matched.
Pretty much the
error is very similar
as it goes on the training data.
When you apply to a data for
which the classifier wasn't
trained, your error is,
of course, much larger.
Prediction is prediction
of the output of the--
so there's a double--
there is a double deep net.
One is classifying,
and then another one
is predicting its output.
One-- and the one
which predicts output
is trained to predict its best
output it can possibly have,
which is the output
on the training data
of the previous classifier.
I don't know if you
follow me or if it
is becoming too complicated.
[CHUCKLES] But
essentially, we are
trying to figure
out if anything like
it is looking on a training--
and applied on the training
data.
So it seems to be
working to some extent.
Here we have a
multi-style results.
matched result. This
is what we would
like to achieve.
Of course this is oracle.
This is what we--
it will be ideal
if we knew which stream is best.
This is what we
would be getting.
But what we are getting
is not that terribly bad.
I mean, certainly, it
is typically better
than a multi-style training.
All right.
And we have some ways
to go to oracle like--
not too far from
the matched trace.
Sometimes it's even
there, because it's making
a decision on every utterance.
So sometimes it can--
going to do quite well.
So we were capable of
picking up the good streams
and leaving out the
best bad streams, even
at the output of the classifier.
How does it work on
previously unseen noise?
Fortunately, for this
example, we still
seem to be getting
some advantage.
We are using noise
which has never
been seen by the classifiers.
But still, it was
capable of picking up
the good classifier,
which is actually better
than any of these classifiers.
Sort of a, so this
seems to be good.
Another technique of
dealing with unseen noises
is actually one which I
like maybe even a bit more,
which is you do
the pre-processing,
and in some processing
in frequency bands,
hoping the main effect
of the different noises
is in the shape, spectral
shape, of different noise.
So if you are doing
recommission in the sub bands,
then the noise start
looking-- in each sub band
starts looking more like
a white noise except
of different levels.
So meaning, it's here, that
maybe the signal to noise ratio
is higher.
Here it is more miserable.
But if I have the
classifier, which
is strained on multiple
levels of the white noise,
in each frequency band perhaps
I can get some advantage.
So I do what in the
cochlear might be doing,
which is I divide each--
the signal into a number of
frequency bands, and then I
have one fusion
DNN which will try
to put these things together.
But each of these
nets are going to be
trained on multiple levels, but
this time of the white noise.
And it's going to get back to
noises which are not white,
or the noise which is not white.
So how it works, you
can figure it out
to see if it was done
in the case of Aurora.
So here we have
the examples here--
how it works on a--
in matched situations.
Here is multi-style training.
But here it is what
you are getting
if you apply this technique.
This is what you get now,
multi-style training.
But in the sub band
recommendation,
you are getting 1/2
of the error rate.
Just a simple
trick which I think
is reasonable, which is you
do the sub band recognition.
There's a number of
power recognized,
each of them paying attention
to part of the spectrum.
And then you-- each
of them is being
trained to head the white
noise, a simple white noise.
But you turn, in some ways,
arbitrary additive noise,
this car noise, into white-like
noise in each sub band.
And that what's you get.
So in general, dealing
with unexpected noise is--
you want to do the adaptation.
You want to modify your
classifier on the fly.
You want to have parts of the
classifier or some streams
which are doing well.
And some of the parts--
so parts of the classifier
are still reliable.
And you want to pick up
these streams which are
reliable on unseen situation.
So this is what we call this
multi-stream recognition--
adapt to multi-stream
adaptation to unknown noise.
So you assume that not all the
streams are going to give you
good result, but you assume that
at least some of the streams
are going to have good results.
And all these streams are being
trained on, say, clean speech
or something.
So this is this multi-band
processing, all right?
So this is what we do.
We do different
frequency ranges.
And then we use our
performance monitor
to pick up the best stream.
So here is the
experiment which we did.
So you would have
the 31 processing
streams created from
all combinations
of fine frequencies.
And one stream was
looking at full spectrum.
And the other things
were only looking
at the parts of the spectrum.
So more black ones, there is
a more spectrum; more white,
some of them are looking only
at a single frequency band.
So we have a decent number
of processing channels,
and we would hope that
if the noise comes here,
maybe this one is going to be
good, because this one is not
going to be--
not worth picking up
this noise, or recognize
that basically which only uses
the bands which are not noisy.
It's going to be good.
So this is the whole system.
It was published in 230--
[STATIC] like a entire speech.
We had this sub band
recognition, fuse,
and performance monitor, and
the selecting of a stream.
This is how it works.
This is again,
showing for car noise.
Car noise is very nice,
because it mainly, it
corrupts the low frequencies.
So all these sub band
techniques work quite well.
But you can see that it's
pretty impressive, and it's--
if you didn't do anything,
you get 50% error.
With this one you get 38% error.
If you knew which
bands to pickup
you would be getting oracle
experiment-- cheating
experiment.
You would be getting about 35%.
So that was, I
thought, quite nice.
Just to conclude-- so, auditory
system doesn't only look like
this, that it starts with
a signal as the analysis,
and then it reduces the--
reduces the bit
rate; but it also
increases number of
views of the signal.
And this is based on
the fact that there
is a massive increase in
number of the cortical neurons
on the level of the cortex.
So there is many ways of
describing information
at high level of perception.
Essentially, the signal
doesn't go through one pass,
but it goes through
many, many passes.
And then we need to have some
means, or we have some means
to pick up the good ones
and ignore the other ones--
maybe switch them entirely off.
This is like vision.
So this is the path of
processing, in general, signal.
You get the different
probability estimates
for different streams.
And then you need to do
some fusion and decide on--
based on the level
of the fusion.
How you can create the streams--
but we were showing you
differently trained probability
estimates on different noises--
different aspects
of signal, that
is, different parts of the
spectrum of the signal.
But you can go wild.
You can start thinking
about different modalities,
because there-- as we talked
about it also in the panel,
you know, very often
audiovisual model,
if it carries the
same information
about the same things,
[STATIC] infusion
of audio visual streams.
You can also imagine
the fusion from streams
with different levels of
priors, different levels
of hallucinations.
So basically, this is what
I see human beings are
doing very often.
If the signal is very noisy,
you are at a cocktail party,
you are guessing,
because that's the best
way to get through if
the communication is not
very important.
It's not about your
salary increase,
but about the weather--
so basically, guessing what
the other people are saying,
especially if they
speak the way I
do, right, with a strong
accent or something.
So the priors are
very important.
And streams with priors
are very important.
We use this to some
extent, I was mentioning,
by comparing the streams of
different-- with different
prior to discover if the signal
is biased in the wrong way
by priors.
So stream formation-- there
is a number of PhD theses
right here, right?
I think.
Fusion-- oh, why?
It's select the best
probability estimates.
I tell you.
This is the problem which
I was actually asking for,
please help me to solve it.
Because we still don't
know how to do that.
I have a-- I suspect
that especially
in human communications,
people are doing it
like this, which
starts making a sense
if they use the certain
processing strategy.
So people can tell if
the output of our--
this perceptual system
makes sense or not.
Our machines don't
know how to do it yet.
Conclusion.
So some problems with
the noise are simple.
You know, you can deal with it
on a signal processing level
by filtering the spectrum,
filtering the trajectories,
because these effects
are very predictable.
And if you understand
them, you should do it.
Because there's no
need to train on that.
They said there is--
you just do it.
And things may be working well.
Unpredictable effects
of noise can be--
typically are being handled by
now by multi-style training.
And these amounts of training
are enormous nowadays.
You know, if you talk
to Google people,
they say we are not deeply
interested in this-- what you
are doing, because we
can always collect more
data from new environments.
But I think it's not--
I shouldn't say dishonest.
I'm sorry.
Scratch it.
[LAUGHTER]
It's not the best
engineering way
of dealing with these
things, because I
think the good engineering way
of dealing with those things
is to get away with less
training and that sort
of thing; and maybe follow what
I believe that human beings are
doing.
So we have a lot of
parallel experts working
with the different
aspects of the signal,
giving us different pictures.
And then we need to pick
up the good ways of being.